Donald Trump Jr has now attacked me and
Unleashed a hate mob against me Candace
Owens is in on it the blaze Infowars how
far is this going to go all because of a
tweet that I since deleted which all of
you understood perfectly
I had tweeted about the shooting in
Nashville tongue-in-cheek of course not
literally blaming the victims of the
shooting something I would never do
that it's surprising that there would be
a shooting at a Christian School given
that it's a Christian school and they
pray every single one of you in my
audience understood the point of the
Tweet thoughts and prayers don't prevent
mass shootings but
right Wingers people who don't know me
all sorts of different folks looking to
contrive controversy and send hate my
way are saying but David you're blaming
the victims you're blaming children of
course I'm not and in fact after
deleting the Tweet because of the number
of threats that rained down upon me I
put out a video a video where I said my
tweet angered about a million people and
I explained the entire thing and of
course that video has almost 100 percent
likes and it has you my viewers who say
David there's not even a controversy
here it's insane that they even turned
this into something but they did
and now this represents the greatest
existential threat to the David packman
show that we have ever faced that is not
an exaggeration they are going after our
advertisers even though they claim to be
against that tactic they're making
threats not only to me but to others in
my circles I won't even do details
because I might just encourage them more
the situation has reached a fever pitch
Don Jr tweeting yesterday imagine being
this big of a POS to his nearly 10
million followers unfortunately this is
what many on the left think of you if
you have traditional American views and
don't follow blindly and capitulate to
their every lunatic whim truly evil at
this point of course if by traditional
American views Don Jr means doing
nothing
about mass shootings which is exactly
what he and his father's Administration
did and want to do
then yeah that's not for me and of
course then the hate mob descended and
it wasn't just Don Jr Candice Owens
devoted a segment on her show to this
where she was almost in tears over my
tweet posting to Twitter quote more
left-wing filth David packman is
laughing at the fact that the dead
children are Christians who believe in
prayer
these are real tweets these people think
it's funny when Christian children die
no I think it's tragic when thoughts and
prayers are the only thing offered by
Republican officials and she is even
going after our advertisers and this is
where this is getting genuinely bad I
wish it wasn't but it is Candace Owens
adding to any of your advertisers who
may be following this this is not a
contrived mob or anti-Semitism this is
you dealing with the consequences of
sending the most horrifically bigoted
tweet directed at dead Christian
children who according to you should
have prayed harder of course that's not
the point the point is thoughts and
prayers don't work who wants to actually
do something about the scourge of gun
violence and yes it's a Scourge that's
how Trump says it and now I say it the
same way a Donald Trump's former lawyer
Jenna Ellis
getting in on it this is a horrific take
that the author didn't walk back just
said he's now getting harassed so
deleted it David Pacman you harassed
Christians and should apologize for this
offensive tweet targeting our sincere
Faith No I'm targeting anyone who says
thoughts and prayers and nothing else
Jenna Ellis says evil persists and we
don't represent prayer as a complete
Shield to The Perils of the Fallen World
but rather than through faith in Christ
we can accept salvation and live it I
mean it just you know religious Babel
now
Thessalonians tells us give me a break
the right wing blaze writing an article
about this they weren't praying enough
progressive radio host goes viral over
vile reaction to Christian school
massacre
thoughts and prayers don't stop mass
shootings that's the point
Infowars is it possible they weren't
praying enough David Pacman mocks
Christians murdered by trans shooter in
Nashville
and the wrongest man in the world on the
pandemic Alex Berenson also tweeting
just apologize David Pacman you were
shameful not just for what you said did
you think it was funny blaming kids for
their own deaths is beyond awful because
in your non-apology you then blamed
anti-Semitism for the response blame
yourself not your religion not blaming
My Religion but you should see
thousands
thousands of anti-Semitic messages
Jew the k word ovens uh uh people
suggesting they're going to come and do
this that the other thing to this and
that the other person I'm not even gonna
I don't I don't even want to put it out
there because it's a deluge where a
security has been contracted and so on
and so forth it you have no idea what's
going on it's wild it is wild so they
are sending the hate mob against us and
we now have to see whether we can
weather this storm most of you reached
out with uh support it's been great
hearing from you know the one upside
when these things happen
is the messages from people who have
been in the audience for a long time and
I got so many messages from people
saying David none of these people are in
your audience we all know what you meant
thoughts and prayers do nothing we've
got to do something about gun violence
you're a father you're frustrated it's
disgusting what's going on don't even
worry about it it'll pass it'll pass uh
I heard from I guess I shouldn't even
say but many of the people you know in
our Circle who do shows like mine they
reached out to me privately and said
this is really bad these are people who
don't know anything about you they don't
follow the show they have seized on to
something to take attention away from
the fact that they have nothing to offer
to actually stop the shootings so we are
getting crushed right now and the best
thing you can do is leave a comment
leave a like try to push back against
this mob which remember isn't even in
our audience and of course if you can
get a membership at joinpakman.com
please do we have the coupon code cancel
cancel
cancel the cancellation that they are
trying to do let me now talk more about
what it is they are trying to do
the right wing hate mob that has been
Unleashed against me
by Donald Trump Jr and Candace Owens and
others listen I'm a big boy I can take
comments on Twitter right but they are
going after our advertisers
and they actually are succeeding to some
degree
some advertisers have already canceled
they don't know what's going on they're
just getting thousands of emails from
people on the right who don't even watch
this show but have been weaponized by
people like Don Jr and Candace Owens
over my uh tweet regarding the Nashville
shooting wherein I was blaming those who
offer only thoughts and prayers and
nothing else now as I've said before
it is a fine legal tactic to use to go
to a Show's advertisers and say you
shouldn't advertise with this person uh
it was a tactic that was used in the
past with Tucker Carlson Etc but use it
when it's appropriate and what is
happening right now and we have we have
examples of this I'm not going to put a
ton of them up but if you look on
Twitter all of these right-wing and
white nationalist accounts are listing
sponsors and then contacting the
sponsors and saying these aren't my
viewers nor are they customers of these
Brands but they are saying you gotta
drop David Pacman now we are doing
everything we can to explain to them
these aren't our viewers and these
aren't your customers this is a
concerted effort in fact even Candace
Owens is leading this effort to some
degree tweeting as I told you earlier to
any of your advertisers who may be
following this this is not a contrived
mob yes it is or anti-Semitism look at
my inbox Candace this is you dealing
with the consequences of sending the
most horrifically bigoted tweet directed
at dead Christian children who according
to you should have prayed harder of
course not my point I I would never
blame the victims of a mass shooting you
all know that but that's what they want
to make it out to be so what we have now
is a situation where we know this is a
contrived mob the video I did about the
situation received nearly a hundred
percent likes versus dislikes because
our audience gets all of it the people
who aren't viewers and aren't customers
of these Brands though
are having success we already got emails
from multiple advertisers saying we are
pausing advertising pausing means it's
over okay this is the most desperate
situation we have ever had over right
Wingers desperate not to deal with gun
safety because understand that that's
what this is they would rather focus on
anything other than gun safety
regulations to prevent shootings in the
future
that's what this is about
and so instead they're going after me
they're more angry about a tweet I sent
saying thoughts and prayers do nothing
to stop shootings than they are about
the dead kids and now they're going
after my advertisers rather than trying
to fix the problem so what you can do
number one write to our advertisers the
ones you see at the end of videos write
to them and say
please keep advertising with David the
people emailing you angry aren't even
his viewers nor are they your customers
second subscribe to the YouTube channel
if we can weather this with a big
increase in subscribers at a time when
the right is trying to end us
it would be huge and the most important
thing is we have to replace that Revenue
we have this is no longer theoretical
this is not about you know it's nicer to
get support from the audience because
then no one person can well listen we
have a mix of support from different
sources advertisers are one of those and
one person can say we're cutting the
campaign and that's what's happening
with a number of these campaigns it is
not theoretical
help us make up for a slice of what
these right-wing radicals have taken
away through the ad campaigns you go to
joinpakman.com we have a coupon code the
code is cancel cancel the cancelers who
say don't cancel people
they are the ones who say don't use
these techniques don't contact
advertisers demanding what they are now
doing it okay the coupon code is cancel
cancel
this is genuinely
a systemic threat to the David packman
show in a week's time I will come back
to you and tell you if and to what
degree we have weathered it Don Jr quite
literally Don Jr is part of the hate mob
trying to end this show that is the
level that this has now reached so I'm
coming to you for support my audience
understands exactly what is going on
uh write to the advertisers subscribe to
the YouTube channel sign up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
cancel cancel I will keep everybody
posted about what's going on My Hope Is
My Hope Is
that we actually come out of this even
stronger which will really upset the
right wing mob
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David pakman show is a community
viewer and listener supported program
that's never been important more
important than right now as Donald Trump
Jr and Candace Owens are quite literally
sending a right-wing hate mob of online
attackers against us I already spoke
about it earlier in the show bear in
mind the importance the precarity of
this situation you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code cancel cancel to get
yourself a discount given the attention
right now on the Nashville school
shooting and on my comments and response
and on the hate mob that has been sent
at me by Don Jr and Candace Owens and
others I am again going to take the
opportunity to talk about what doesn't
work to reduce gun violence in mass
shootings and what does now I want to
contextualize this by reminding you that
you have
very uh uh sort of pathetic solutions
from the right which they don't even
actually believe in which we know
because they don't fund them I'll give
you an example they say say mass
shootings are really about mental health
well mental health might well be a
component but if you believe that you
should fund mental health treatment
services which they do not and in fact
in many states every time there's a
proposal to increase funding for exactly
those types of services they are against
funding it they don't want to do it we
say the problems mental health but we
won't do anything about it of course the
ubiquitous and ever-present thoughts and
prayers before thoughts and prayers and
after thoughts and prayers and thoughts
and prayers and thoughts and prayers and
the thoughts and prayers do nothing the
thoughts and prayers do nothing if
prayer is important to you in difficult
situations then by all means do it but
it is not policy to reduce gun violence
more recently now they are targeting
trans people drag shows gender affirming
care because of the trans identity of
the shooter in Nashville Tennessee give
me a break give me a break now if we
could somehow pass legislation if we
miraculously had the ability to get
build consensus and actually pass some
gun safety legislation
what would I do such that we would make
an impact I am going to give you the
disclaimer up front that I always do no
one of the bullet points I'm about to
list would prevent every mass shooting
not we have 340 million people in this
country
and every combination of mass shooting
no one rule would prevent every mass
shooting but taken together these 10
policies would significantly reduce the
number of mass shootings number one end
the Gun Show loophole The Gun Show
loophole is the fact that federal law
doesn't require unlicensed private
sellers to perform background checks on
gun purchasers you go and you buy a a
gun at a dealer and they do the
background check great now if you make a
private sale you as an individual with
no license to sell firearms if you make
a private sale to someone else you are
not required by federal law to have that
buyer background checked some states
require it but there is no federal law
and as a result many states don't
require it would it solve every shooting
no but that is just obvious that should
be done number two Universal background
checks it would require almost all
firearms transactions in the United
States to go through the nics national
instant Criminal background check system
this is also part of closing the private
sale exemption so you've got the Gun
Show loophole and the private sale
exemption both are about getting around
background checks
um at least 22 States and DC require
background checks for Private Sales but
they are not required by federal law
number three mandatory waiting period
from when you go in and say I'd like a
gun please and when you get the gun
it won't prevent every shooting some
people some Shooters have guns that
they've had for years but for those who
are going and saying I want to do a
shooting let me go and get the gun and
you get it that day for some of them a
mandatory waiting period maybe it's five
days maybe it's ten days might actually
allow cooler heads to Prevail and might
reduce the number of these shootings
number four no high capacity weapons for
those under age 25 but David they could
get a handgun yes they could but in many
of these incidents not all but in many
of these incidents with a handgun rather
than an AR-15 the number dead would be
lower and fewer people dying is better
I'd rather zero but fewer is better
number five mandatory gun insurance
which is significantly more expensive
without apparent co-signing if you were
under 25 this is both a financial
disincentive which might just make the
entire thing more expensive particularly
for those under 25 remember when we look
at Mass Shooters overwhelmingly under
age 25. if you don't have a parent
saying yeah I think this makes sense and
we're going to get the insurance it is
dramatically more expensive number six
if you're under 25 and you want to get a
gun you should be required to provide
one maybe two Community Support letters
these would be letters from adults who
know you not your parents who say I am
fine with this individual having these
Firearms I have no issues with that and
if there are issues it doesn't mean any
random person in the community can say
no guns but it would require a more
scrutiny and maybe if someone goes and
tries to get a gun and a teacher and
whoever else says I have concerns about
this individual or if they're not even
able to find such individuals
then maybe that person shouldn't be able
to get guns number seven some weapons
should be banned there are simply there
are some weapons that are simply of no
recreational or any other value other
than as mass killing machines I'm not
pretending I have the exact list right
here in front of me people will disagree
about what should be on the list most
people think the shoulder mounted RPGs
should be not allowed most people
believe the handguns should be allowed
well now we're now we're negotiating now
we have to find what is the point there
are some weapons that should be banned
number eight there should be a periodic
mental health evaluation there should be
a mental health evaluation at the
beginning and there should be a mental
health evaluation periodically oh but
David that'll be expensive well it
should be paid by the licensing fees
which maybe are too low
that's another issue to discuss but
there should be a periodic mental health
evaluation you might be fine to have a
gun at 25 and then at 30 things have
changed and if you were subjected to a
mental health eval a mental health
professional might say you really
shouldn't have this gun
number nine the licensing process should
be more extensive you need a written and
a practical test for a driver's license
at minimum it should be the same for
guns the training and Licensing period
shouldn't be one weekend it should be
longer more like with cars where there
are hours of uh driver's ed and
practical all the why not well because
the right-wing gun lobby has prevented
it from being that way and then number
10 there should be a gun buyback program
give people an off-ramp that feels
better than supposed gun confiscation no
one of these things will stop every
specific shooter someone will write and
they'll say David but number nine
wouldn't have stopped the Uvaldi shoot
the point here is
we would stop some of the shootings
and we would be able to then say look at
the Improvement where can we tweak where
can we do more we have a second
amendment
none of these affect that
but we could be doing so much more but
none of this stuff will happen
with the current Republican party and
the NRA as powerful as it is
also
am I saying mental health isn't an issue
no the reason I want the mental health
evaluations is because I'm agreeing a
factor is mental health
there's also the cultural issue the
United States
is unique and many Americans don't
understand how weird it is to see
Firearms fetishized violence celebrated
intelligence condemned we need a
cultural change where people stop seeing
Firearms as the solutions to personal or
social problems I don't know how in hell
we do that that's a big issue in the
meantime though
10 policies all of which would prevent
some mass shootings so the thoughts and
prayers don't work I stand by that
here's 10 ideas that might and you know
what what do we have to lose we're not
fixing it do we've done nothing and it
hasn't solved the problem maybe it's
time to try something new Ted Cruz went
on a complete manic tear yesterday
during a senate hearing with the United
States Secretary of Homeland Security
Alejandro mallorcas this is Ted Cruz
auditioning for Fox News when Ted Cruz
wants to get himself on Fox News either
interviewed or have his Clips played he
does these sort of manic scream fests
with oversized poster boards behind him
and he certainly pulled out all the
stops yesterday take a look at this and
in in fact if you look
at illegal immigration let's look at CBP
encounters you can see 500 500 000 it
drops to the lowest level and boom what
happens you show up and that red line is
you now let's talk about that couple
different things here this this they
love this they love to say the number of
encounters with border patrol went up
when Joe Biden became the president now
there are two really important things to
understand about that number one
mobility in general was really really
low during the pandemic and in fact you
can see that on the chart that Ted Cruz
has behind him what we started to see
was as the pandemic eased and the
weather improved a huge backlog of
people who would have tried to cross
previously tried to cross the border but
here's the most important thing
when encounters show up on this chart
it's because the people were stopped the
people were stopped it if you're going
to argue that the borders are open and
people are just going through you can't
defend that by saying look at all these
people stopped by border patrol by
definition that's because the Border
isn't open that red line is Joe Biden
and you're claiming nothing happened oh
gosh this was here before us no you made
the decision to allow this to happen let
me ask you we now have over 5.5 million
people who've entered this country
illegally under Joe Biden how many
murderers Have You released into America
what I'm not aware of any murder so you
don't know
Senator let me say something if you you
know if you take a look at no and this
is Ted Cruz not actually wanting to get
answers about anything this is a
performance piece and a pretty bad one
at that
you can answer I know or I don't know
Senator any individual who poses a
public safety threat how many child
molesters Have You released and removed
into the United States from the United
States and this word of releasing is
straight out of the Trump Playbook Trump
has been insisting quote mental
institutions are being emptied out and
released into the United States of
course that's not happening this is a
tryout this is a performance so you your
testimony under oath subject to perjury
is that you have not released any
murderers rapists or child molesters
among the 5.5 million is that your
testimony
um Mr chairman may I have the
opportunity no you may not you may
answer my question
you're you're not is that your testimony
yes or no Senator you're not allowing me
to answer your I am allowing you to
answer I'm not allowing you to feel
about it if you take a look at the the
pace of immigration in 2018 to 2019.
you're refusing to answer let's move on
let's move on to God aways yeah
um this is not how you learn anything
this is not how you fix anything this is
not this is really nothing this is no
it's not of any value here's more of it
if Ted Cruz just losing his mind these
are modern day leg irons because these
are children being sold into sex slavery
and you don't even know what they are
that is astonishing Mr secretary how
many children have been sold into sex
slavery under your Administration
Senator we are taking it to the cartel
how many children have been sold into
sex slavery do you know how many
children I mean how many were sold under
Trump the idea that because the number
isn't zero under any Administration that
it's this particular individual's fault
is absurd told in the sex slavery
unprecedented degree Mr secretary I want
to say to you right now your behavior is
disgraceful and the deaths the children
assaulted the children raped they are at
your feet and what about all of the ones
under Trump given that this is a global
issue it's not about minimizing it's
well it's very capricious and arbitrary
for Ted Cruz to be indignant when Biden
is president but to never have said
anything about the exact same thing
under Trump if you had Integrity you
would resign
I will tell you the men and women if Ted
Cruz had Integrity he would have
resigned border patrol they've never had
a political leader undermine them they
despise you Mr secretary because you're
willing to let children be raped
to follow political orders this is a
crisis it's a disgrace and you won't
even admit this human tragedy is a
crisis
claiming one minute chairman time Mr
secretary would you like to respond to
any of those emotions what the senator
said was revolting I'm not going to
address it
I mean it's like why honestly why bother
why bother this is of no value or
meaning that is Ted Cruz desperate for
relevance
excited about the possibility of being
featured in compilations on Fox news of
what happened at the hearing uh that he
is just screaming and doing the sort of
Lindsey Graham routine that's the that's
the sort of routine Lindsey Graham the
Republican senator did during the
confirmation hearings of eventual
Supreme Court Justice Brett Kavanaugh
scream and act indignant and be furious
of people and it probably does make it
on to Fox News but we see through it
it's completely pathetic
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so it
turns out that there's actually a part
two to the Fox news interview that
Donald Trump did with Sean Hannity we
looked at part one yesterday and we are
going to look at a little bit of part
two today this is a part of the
interview that is significantly more
understated in tone but it is
significantly scarier to many of you who
have been emailing me and saying David
what exactly is Trump talking about and
is he really serious about this stuff
also of course raising questions of
Trump's cognitive State as is always the
case were they Freudian slips were they
brain glitches well we're going to
figure that out the second part of the
interview included Donald Trump
bizarrely claiming that he got rid of
NATO and built usmca now Sean Hannity
helps Trump out and then as you can see
Trump looks very confused Hannity helps
Trump out and says you mean NAFTA not
NATO you got rid of NAFTA and built
usmca but even that actually isn't
really much to write home about and I'll
explain that in a moment check out this
bizarre moment where Hannity quite
literally has to help Trump out of this
mess so if I made a lot of great trade
deals I changed a lot of those deals
where it was a bad deal for us now it's
a good like usmca with NATO I got rid of
NATO and built usmca I made a great
draft deal with China our farmers are to
this day notice that Hannity tried to
sneak in NAFTA Trump just steamrolls it
made tremendous money because of the
deal but because of covet I don't even
talk about that deal because that
overrid you know overrode everything
right so a completely insane what Donald
Trump is talking about says he got rid
of NATO to replace it with usmca of
course he didn't what he got did what he
did was replace NAFTA with usmca a
couple interesting things here number
one of course to some degree you could
say this is a Freudian slip Donald Trump
was one of the most hostile to Nato
American presidents and when he says I
got rid of NATO he would have liked to
get rid of NATO to have gotten rid of
NATO he didn't and instead he just it's
just a Freudian slip the other aspect to
this is that the continued claim that
replacing NAFTA with usmca is some kind
of major accomplishment it's basically
NAFTA with marginally different
Provisions about automobile
manufacturing with a new name and it is
true that usmca differs from NAFTA in
that it changes the requirements for
vehicle manufacturing what percentage of
the part versus the labor needs to be
done where
but it is very similar to NAFTA and
again claiming it as some kind of big
legislative Victory is very very silly I
almost thought that it was like doctored
but it was just a Freudian slip I guess
uh Donald Trump also saying that if he's
elected here you know how Trump does
this thing where he can't help himself
he always has to make the promise more
grandiose and he has to make the claim
more grandiose there were 5 000 people
at my rally there were tens of thousands
there were tens of thousands and it's
probably double that he just can't stick
to reality he used to say he would fix
the Russian invasion of Ukraine on his
first day as president now he's saying
he would fix it even before taking
office which is again he's he always has
to go first I would fix that within
24 hours and if I win before I get into
office I will have that War settled 100
sure and everything I said yeah of
course that's not the case it doesn't
make any sense and Sean Hannity really
doing his best you know the hand
anything is interesting that this
two-night special interview with Donald
Trump
it does serve as evidence that at least
overtly Hannity is still on the Trump
train we know that Hannity was involved
in the Fox News text messages behind the
scenes that are part of the Dominion
lawsuit he expressed concern about some
of the things that were being repeated
he expressed concern about Sydney Powell
and so on and so forth but at least
publicly he seems to be very glad to
give Trump these total softball
interviews allowed Trump to lie lie lie
and present no pushback and so it's
interesting in the context of what is
the next year going to look like if
indeed this is a a heavily contested
primary right now I don't call the
Republican primary contested in the
sense that there are other people
running but it's Nikki Haley and Vivek
ramaswamy neither has a shot DeSantis is
polling pretty well but he's not
actually running so if DeSantis says I'm
running and if his polling doesn't
continue declining then we will say okay
now we've got a real primary on our
hands so far I can't really say that
that's the case Trump's Theory on
Chinese politics is that she is in
charge because the smartest person gets
to the top and I sort of think Trump is
trying to analogize to himself here
Trump sees himself as a very stable
genius and he seems to be analogizing
that also in the United States the
smartest person gets to the top as
evidenced by Trump having been president
for four years it's an age thing I think
a person running for
president you couldn't even say running
for certain offices if you want to know
the truth now I don't know if it's
constitutional because people would say
it's not constitutional but I would say
that if you could do it but I'd like to
see it for anybody running for president
I think somebody from running for
president taking a cognitive test you
know they do it in China but it's done a
different way they have a caste system
isn't that nice guys the caste system of
China will allow you to figure out who
is fit for Duty and who is smart it I
mean it's it's not even sort of like uh
but benevolent dictator stuff it's just
straight up she is great China's caste
system this is wild stuff scary to the
rest of the world
and the smartest person gets to the top
I'm glad the smartest for talk shows and
the media people and people in the Press
you've proven yourself
um at the highest level you can so Trump
just gushing about the intelligence of
she as well as the caste system
genuinely horrifying stuff lastly Donald
Trump tells Hannity there wouldn't have
been any Chinese spy balloons under my
watch and of course there were Chinese
spy balloons under Trump's watch and
what would you have done with the
balloon and what would you have done if
Putin took down one of your drones I
wouldn't have done anything with a
balloon because it wouldn't happen under
me wouldn't happen they wouldn't have
sent the balloon if this is a big
balloon this is a balloon where you can
see it from it's like three bucks 75 000
feet away people are looking but it's
rain to see it up there we only found
out because of a guy in Montana they
wouldn't have done it I'm just telling
you just like Putin would have never
gone into Ukraine so Trump says they
wouldn't have done it except they did
now it is true Trump didn't find out
about it until later that that's
absolutely true I'm not pretending Trump
knew about the balloons when he was
President we have now learned that there
were multiple instances of Chinese spy
balloons overflying the United States
while Trump was President Trump's claim
understand is they wouldn't have done it
if I were president but they did it when
you were president he wasn't told there
was some kind of decision made
um by I guess it was the Pentagon that
it didn't need to get to Trump but they
literally did it while Trump was
president and he wants you to believe
they simply wouldn't do it if he was
president again
scary interview the romanticizing the
continued romanticizing of
authoritarians and wannabe dictators and
seeing them as just smart and great and
they've got these great systems they
don't have to deal with the Press they
just crush the Press they don't have to
deal with courts that might indict them
they just control the cords he loves
dictator type scenarios because he sees
them as the easiest thing for him if he
were to govern and he's not wrong
wasn't it George W bush who said it'd be
much easier if it was a dictatorship
um Trump seems to really want that
Donald Trump is also now admitting he's
going to try to cheat in 2024. Mike
pillow found out about this and is not
in agreement with Donald Trump this is
super super interesting Donald Trump put
out a statement I missed this originally
but this is just Bonker stuff Trump put
out a statement saying we need to beat
Democrats in 2024. and of course the
Democrats cheat it's like no no no you
tried to steal the election but put that
aside he insists Democrats chief we need
Trump says to start ballot harvesting
just like they do we need to do the
ballot harvesting now Mike pillow has
been slamming ballot harvesting alleging
that Democrats do it and I'll explain
what it is in a moment
for two years now so pillow's Furious so
let's listen to what Trump had to say
first the radical left Democrats have
used ballot harvesting to cancel out
your vote and walk away with elections
that they never should have won they
cheat and they cheat like nobody's ever
cheated before
many states have bad ballot harvesting
to keep our elections honest and fair
but in the states where ballot
harvesting is still legal we have no
choice but to beat the Democrats at
their own game it's very simple either
we start ballot harvesting
or you can say goodbye to our country
you want to wave goodbye because
Democrats would win every single
election we have to get smart and that's
why our campaign will fight back and
start harvesting ballots whoa the states
where the left has been cheating the
scourge of ballot harvesting which they
will now participate in the system and
hurting our country but our harvested
ballots will only come from legal
registered voters who are American
citizens ah you're going to harvest
ballots but from legal voters whereas
Democrats were harvesting ballots from
illegal voters
with your help we will Master the
Democrats game of ballot harvesting and
we will win back the White House from
Joe Biden and the people that are
destroying our country okay so ballot
harvesting means you collect and submit
com completed ballots on behalf of
Voters so the idea is there's someone
who says I will collect the ballots you
fill your ballot out I will go and
collect it and it's a technique used to
increase voter turnout especially when
there are people who have a tough time
getting to polling stations either
because they uh live very rarely and
don't have a car or they have a physical
limitation or a whatever the reason may
be in general the term ballot harvesting
means oh I will go and collect ballots
now the legality varies from state to
state and jurisdiction to jurisdiction
in some places it's legal and regulated
in some places it's illegal some states
say you can do it but you can only do it
for family members and caregivers you
can't just have the person on your block
who says I'll collect everyone's ballots
and drop them off or whatever the case
may be it's become a very Hot Topic in
the U.S recently
because
the right is arguing the left harvests
ballots but they do it with coercion
they encourage voter fraud they get a
bunch of illegal voters to fill out
ballots and then they collect them
there's no evidence of any of this stuff
but it's what the story they've been
telling so Trump's saying we should do
it puts Mike pillow in sort of a strange
position and Mike pillow says I spoke to
Trump about this he's never going to say
it again it's a voter fraud but also
recently he's been saying let's beat the
left at their own game at least until we
get into office so that no no no no
don't even go there I've talked to him
about that we are not going to do what
they're doing we're not going to ballot
Harvest we want we and you will not hear
him saying that this is we've worked two
years to give to get same-day voting
paper ballots handcuffs he's a I've been
I've been killing myself I spent 35
million
fighting against ballot harvesting and
now Trump's going to do it on a no
machine and if you say that we want to
do what they do ballot Harvest and do
this the the Republicans would just make
it legal to do what's illegal in a lot
of States and it's over we lose our
country so that narrative you will not
hear him saying that anymore I don't I
don't even want it yeah pillow didn't
even really want to talk about it so
pillow says no no no no no no no I heard
about that I went to Trump we're not
going to be talking about that anymore
we can't really do it so this is this is
obviously fascinating and it doesn't
seem totally clear to me whether Donald
Trump understands
the the issue is less about obviously
any kind of ballot collection regardless
of the state or jurisdiction you can
only collect legal ballots like if you
somehow again imagine the scenarios they
dream up if you somehow find ten
thousand blank ballots and bring them to
people who aren't registered to vote I
guess you have to find find 10 000
undocumented immigrants who of course
they're going to live all over the place
and you're going to drive around
Distributing ballots to undocumented
immigrants and then picking them up
obviously that's illegal because the
voters aren't legal registered voters
The Collection is what's at issue in
some places anyone can collect ballots
for others in other places it's limited
to family or caregivers there are
different rules in different places in
Trump's mind he's just like well
Democrats do ballot harvesting but with
illegal ballots whereas we're going to
do it with only legal citizens but we're
going to help them he doesn't even
actually understand the controversy over
ballot harvesting which isn't surprising
because increasingly he doesn't really
understand anything
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
a timely discussion to have given that a
mob sent by Don Jr and Candace Owens is
actively trying to cancel me right now
is to ask whether the so-called victims
of cancel culture
have actually been canceled
the term cancel culture is used to
describe the social phenomenon where a
person or a group is ostracized or
they're boycotted because of their
opinions or their actions when someone
considers it offensive or controversial
or whatever the case may be and the
question that I think is interesting to
consider is even in cases where there is
a cancellation alleged to have taken
place was anyone actually canceled
because in many cases those who complain
about being canceled are facing
consequences that make sense for the
behavior or statements that are in
question like for example former
president Donald Trump was banned from
several social media platforms when he
repeatedly spread false information
about the 2020 election he incited
violence which led to the storming of
the capital and on and on
it wasn't cancel culture it was Twitter
has certain terms and conditions and
thus the
blocking or Banning of trump from
Twitter was a response to Trump's
irresponsible actions but Trump is still
super wealthy he finished out his term
as president he continues to have the
bully pulpit he's running again he is
making money was he really canceled
because the terms of service on Twitter
were applied to him I would argue not
really
uh comedian Louis C.K faced a bunch of
backlash and he did lose a few gigs
after he admitted to what I think we're
now calling sexual misconduct covers
Louis CK's Behavior was that a
cancellation or was it he admitted to
something that some found reprehensible
it temporarily had an effect but he's
produced multiple quite successful
comedy specials since then is that
really a cancellation
or is it something else comedian Kevin
Hart faced some backlash he lost his
role as hosting the Oscars when some
homophobic tweets resurfaced but he kept
working he's hosted other events
including
um I think the MTV Video Music Awards
the Academy Awards pre-show is that
really a cancel cancellation or there
were briefly some consequences to
something that he did or said
Dave Chappelle comedian Dave Chappelle
faced significant criticism for some
material about trans people in his
Netflix special his career continues to
thrive he's released multiple special
since I think he signed a pretty
lucrative deal with Netflix for multiple
more things he still gets on Rogan
regularly and he is gets the heroes
welcome whenever Rogan brings him out
was he canceled or was it there was a
period during which there were
consequences to things he said JK
Rowling the Harry Potter author she has
faced backlash and accusations of
transphobia because she made some
statements about trans people on social
media she keeps releasing successful
books and adaptations the Fantastic
Beasts film series and on and on you
could say well she's big enough to be
uncancelable but then isn't that sort of
the point where like so she wasn't
actually canceled Roseanne Barr also
also comes to mind and then we'll move
on to Academia Roseanne Barr
face consequences when she made uh some
remarks on Twitter
and she later ended up back on TV with a
new show after some version of Roseanne
was canceled and now she's doing the
circuit and she's given the hero's
welcome everywhere so were they really
canceled if that's how it ends up now we
can also talk about Academia you know in
Academia it's been a little different
Stephen Pinker cognitive psychologist he
faced backlash for some of the things he
said about race and gender and he's
continued to teach he's continued to
have popular books was that really a
cancellation he was criticized widely
Jordan Peterson right I mean look he's
doing far better now than he was when he
was teaching psychology at uh University
of Toronto I believe it was there were
protests and there were all sorts of
criticisms and complaints and he was
um you know brought to testify before
Canadian Parliament and people are
saying they're canceling Jordan Peterson
he's as successful as ever
uh so when when I think of it Milo
yiannopoulos was more or less canceled
in what we might call a meaningful way
he was dropped by his publisher speaking
events were published after he made some
comments that some people said were
condoning pedophilia others said it's
not really pedophilia it's really
hemophilia but you could make the
argument that was a response to his
offensive remarks is it a cancellation
Mel Gibson I mean quite frankly deserved
it but he did get back to working even
after a Hiatus after his incident
involving a police officer are you
Jewish and the entire drunk driving uh
stop so the idea that cancel culture is
a threat to free speech and attempt to
silence dissenting voices is it
criticism is it consequence what is it I
think that that's perfectly fair to
explore right again right now the right
wing mob is trying to cancel me by
calling my advertisers and saying don't
advertise with David because he blamed
the victims of a shooting for the
shooting which of course I didn't do
I blamed our politicians who send only
thoughts and prayers
it's a tactic that is completely fine to
say hey I don't like what was said give
a consequence in my particular case it's
being done in bad faith I think with Al
Franken it went too far uh but the vast
majority of these cancellations don't
really seem to even be cancellations
whether they're warranted or not we can
debate but are they even really
cancellations let me know what you think
I missed this and did not have time to
talk about it until today
um this guy from Newsmax Rob Murphy who
is on the bandwagon attacking me on
Twitter uh over the last few days for
the controversy about the Nashville
shooting he interviewed failed former
president Donald Trump and Trump said
something bizarre Donald Trump said that
he appointed Ron DeSantis governor now
that didn't happen
it simply didn't happen there's there's
no way in which that could even be
remotely interpreted as accurate listen
to this strangeness about Rhonda sanus
he told Eric Bolling last night that he
thinks the New York Alvin Bragg probe is
a political Stunt by George Soros he
also said he would not consider being
your vice president in 2024. I want to
ask was there was that ever an option
for you
no I never thought of it I think that we
have a lot of great people in the
Republican party I never thought of it
but uh you know some people every once
in a while mention it but that's about
it no I think that would be a very
unlikely Alliance but you know look I
appointed him he was failing badly in
the public he was out of politics he was
going to be out of politics and I
endorsed him and he went from a very
small number to a very high number you
you appointed him
What on earth does that mean is does
Trump mean that his endorsement was such
a lifesaver to desanctus that it was
like an appointment Trump saying I
endorse you is almost as good as Trump's
saying I appoint you the governor of
Florida very very strange Trump then
talking about January 6th and he says he
made beautiful statements despite the
fact that he incited a riot I'm
president of the United States I made
beautiful statements if you look at my
statements I wish you could read them
off to your viewers which by the way I
see you're doing very well so I'm proud
of you rob yeah but I wish you could
read them off to the viewers but I
called for peace I called for all of
these different things on numerous
occasions yes he also used the words
fight or fighting more than 20 times and
quite literally incited a riotous mob a
trump asked about
um DeSantis Moore and he went after
DeSantis for his covet numbers which is
super in interesting I'll explain why in
a moment you both but that's that's
Politics as we move into primary season
here I want to ask you you have to get
to work out though up and you know I
don't like saying this about another
Republican but you have to you know
everyone thought he did greater than
covet but if you look at the list he did
poorly uncovered he was in the numbers
the same numbers as New York a little
bit worse than New York he's bad on
education bad on covet bad on many
different things that people don't know
about so you know now you know what
Trump is right it's just funny because
Florida to Republicans is either The
Shining Beacon of freedom and liberty
in a sea of wokeness when it's
convenient or it's sort of like not that
great
if you want to criticize Ron DeSantis
and I have made this case before
Florida's per capita Cova death rate is
very so-so it's not the worst and it's
not the best it's just like kind of
mediocre that's true Trump's right
education in Florida it's not very good
it's not as bad as in Arkansas or
Mississippi
but it's not very good either it's not
Connecticut or New York or Massachusetts
or Maine so Trump actually is right here
it's just funny that they're only
they're only willing to say this stuff
we all know
when it's convenient for them which
shouldn't come as a shock Trump was
asked about his choice to hold that
rally over the weekend in Waco Texas on
the 30th anniversary of the Waco Siege
he completely ignores the question about
this rally tomorrow in Waco Texas you're
holding a massive rally it's going to be
televised here on Newsmax of course next
month marks 30 years though since uh
that deadly government Siege of the
Branch Davidian compound there we've got
the mainstream media right now accusing
you of quote stoking the fires of Waco
with this visit and with that location I
just wanted to get your thoughts on that
and and what people can expect from the
rally tomorrow yeah well I hear there's
10 thousands of people I mean we're
going to have
you know many many tens of thousands the
line is already miles long
trying to get in and I don't leave until
tomorrow late afternoon and we're going
to have a great time in Waco we're going
to have a great time in Texas I want
Texas by a lot two times as you know and
we have tremendous support in Texas we
have a lot of the congressmen are coming
a lot of the great people in politics
are coming and uh most importantly the
people of Texas are going we're going to
have it's going to be a very big rally
we're just now starting our rallies
because people love the rallies so we're
just now starting the rallies and this
will be about the first one that we've
done we've done interior things but this
is the first major rally and and I think
they're bigger than ever before that I
really see it okay so again Trump not
answering the actual question about the
fact that he's in Waco and all of the
imagery and all of the insanity of doing
that and then lastly hear Trump going
after his former lawyer and friend of
the David Pacman show Michael Cohen it
was just the opposite
this whole thing in exactly the opposite
way it which really showed that cone was
lying he was lying badly but he's known
for that you know he's sort of a con man
and again he was a lawyer who
represented other people and uh you're
supposed to have a certain allegiance to
a client you know nowadays that doesn't
mean so much with all of these uh
prosecutors out there so Trump bemoaning
that even his own lawyers aren't loyal
to him really deranged interview
celebrated by Newsmax there will be much
more of this to come
and I predict it is going to get much
much worse from the things that Trump
has been posting to Troth Central I
think this sort of insanity is only
going to get worse we have a voicemail
number that number is 219 to David P
here's a caller who is disgusted with
the hate mob Unleashed upon me by Donald
Trump Jr listen to this
hi David I just saw your video regarding
the Tweet you removed
I think you did the right thing I but
you know removing it I guess because
imagine the hypocrisy of these people
there first of all anyone who knows who
listens to you should know
exactly what you meant by that tweet
um so that's disturbing but the fact
that they would threaten you and your
family come on people this is what they
do it's just
just disgusting yes and you are correct
um obviously if thoughts and prayers
stop this we wouldn't have this problem
and I do agree you know I think people
if they if prayer works for them that's
great do that but we need to take action
legislatively pray but allow politicians
to do things
um you know and call and write and just
press our all our Representatives on the
local state and federal levels
this is inexcusable and one thing that I
feel like never gets discussed really in
the mainstream media at least is the
fact that the GOP is in bed with the NRA
of course and in fact in my video that I
did yesterday I do discuss it because it
must be discussed uh accurate voicemail
I have nothing to add we have a great
voice a bonus show for you today we will
talk about Joe Biden's reaction to the
Nashville shooting and his urging of an
assault weapons ban we're also going to
talk about hand scanning technology
rolled out at Panera that has privacy
Advocates very concerned are they
warranted in being concerned we will
discuss and lastly a conspiracy theory
about a body double for John fetterman
has actually gotten a bunch of attention
it's pretty nuts we will talk about all
of it on the bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com use the coupon code
cancel cancel to get yourself a discount